I pretty sure we all know the answer
[Music]
[Applause]
well it's gonna be hard to dodge the
romance rumors now because Shawn Mendes
and Camila Cabello where K is s ing in
the ocean oh yeah take a close look
actually you don't even need to take a
close look because the photo is that
crystal clear sha mila smooching in
Miami Beach on Monday and that's not all
seems like they knew the cameras had
caught them in this pic of course this
isn't the first time the pair has been
snapped smooching there was also this
video
[Music]
so I know some of you guys think this is
all a PR stunt but I kind of don't
because friends also don't just kiss and
yeah hold hands on the beach which is
what they are doing here we also got
this picks on getting out of the ocean
with his new tat on full display
so you probably know Sean and Camilla
have been packing on the PDA aisle over
Florida these past few days check them
out our man armed at Oxford exchange in
Tampa and here sipping coffee chatting
one-on-one when eyewitness told us they
were being flirty with each other and
quote they were kissing she had her hand
on his leg
yeah and this isn't the first time
Camila has joined Sean on the road she
also joined him in California earlier
this month I just want to know if Camila
will be at Sean's show in Orlando on
Tuesday or in Atlanta or should I say a
hot Lanta on Wednesday if you see you
there let me know all right guys what do
you think is this romance the real deal
should we expect to see Camila
continue to travel with Sean let me know
let's chat and for all the latest on
Sean and Camila keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krauss and bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]